The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, good afternoon.
Our subject for all of today
and some part of Monday
is coherence in
free-level systems.
And what I want to
show you are there
are certain fundamentally
new and, to some extent,
surprising processes
which are possible when
you have three levels
and not only two.
Because when you
have three levels,
you have one excited
state which is
coupled to two ground states.
And that gives us the
possibility of interference.
And actually, all
the special things
I will tell you about
three-level system
are related to interference.
Certain phenomena will
constructively interfere.
Other will
destructively interfere.
And that leads to a number
of important effects.
The first effect you
want to talk about
is the possibility
of dark states,
that there are
superposition states which
are bombarded with two laser
beams, and they're not excited.
Because the amplitudes to go to
the excited state destructively
interfere.
When you have a
state which is dark,
which cannot absorb the light,
then you already understand
the possibility of doing
lasing without inversion.
Because if a lot of the
population is in a dark state,
you don't have to invert
excited and ground state.
Because the dark
state doesn't count.
Lasing without inversion is
a little bit more intricate
than this, but just
kind of the idea,
the notion of a dark
state helps you already
to anticipate why something
like lasing with inversion
may be possible.
The dark state is only dark
in a very narrow frequency
interval of the two lasers.
So if you're a very
narrow resonance,
then you have a very
narrow resonance
where something goes dark.
But if something goes
dark, it's not absorbing.
And therefore you have
electromagnetically
induced transparency, which
is a very, very sharp feature
in frequency space.
And when you have very, very
sharp features in frequency,
you can change the
group velocity of light,
because if transmission and
absorption index of refraction
changes a functional
frequency very,
very sharply, you have huge
effects on propagation lights.
So kind of all of these
different subjects which
I want to go through are
different perspectives,
but you will find
similar physics.
It's just we look
at interference.
We look at dark states
in various ways.
And each of them has
created a cottage industry
and a subfield of itself.
So I started to
remind you that you're
very familiar with the dark
state in the situation where
we have optical pumping.
If you have two ground
states in an excited state,
and you switch only one
laser, sooner or later you
will just pump all the
atoms into the state f
and the state f is
dark, and vice versa.
So what I want to show you now
is that even if both lasers are
on, then no matter in what kind
of state or superposition state
you have the atoms,
the atoms see
light, which is
ready to excite them.
But there is-- and this is
what I want to show you now--
a coherent superposition state,
which is still the dark state.
So the last thing I did on
Monday, I wrote down for you
our Hamiltonian,
which is nothing
else in the well-known dipole
Hamiltonian in the rotating
wave approximation.
And what is important now
is that we have pathways
with Rabi frequency
omega 1 and omega 2.
And we have one laser fields.
The photons are
created, annihilated
by the a operator, and
the second laser field,
where the operator
is C and C dega.
So there are two ways how
we go to the excited state.
We can couple from the ground
state f to the excited state
and from the ground state
to g to the excited state.
So when you shine
on the light, atoms
may be in some initial state.
They will sort of spontaneously
emit but scatter light.
But then after some
transient, the state
which is stable against further
illumination, is a dark state.
That's like optical pumping.
So you will optically pump
into the following state,
which I write down for you.
And then we can inspect that
indeed it is a dark state.
It is a coherent superposition
of the two ground states.
And the coefficient
involves the Rabi frequency,
omega 2 of laser 2,
omega 1 of laser 1.
And we just normalize it by
taking the quadrature some
of the two Rabi frequencies.
So this state is
indeed a dark state.
So let me show that
to you by looking
what happens when we
expose it to this operator.
This operator v
in the Hamiltonian
is the operator which couples
the atoms to light, which
couples the atom to
the excited state
and this causes
spontaneous emission.
So what I want to show
you that is a dark state,
since if you take this operator,
apply it to the dark state
and ask, is there
any possibility
how you can excite, how you can
excite to the excited state?
And the answer is,
it will be zero.
The dark state has a
component on-- the dark state
has one component in f, and
it has one component in g.
How did I want to do that?
Sometimes it's easier
to say it in words
than to write down
a long equation.
The light atom interaction
couples the component
of the ground state
to the excited state
with Rabi frequency omega 1
and the state f with omega 2.
However, in the construction
of the dark state,
I've made sure that the
amplitude of the component g
is omega 2.
So therefore when we
apply this operator,
we have omega 1 from the
operator and omega 2 here.
And here we also get
omega 1 and omega 2.
And this minus sign means
the two effects cancel.
So therefore, I've
shown you that even
though in its full frame with
second quantization, photon
operators and all this,
this coupling is identically
0 and therefore we
have a dark state.
So this phenomenon of
having a dark state
and populating the dark
state by light scattering,
you have spontaneous
emission into the dark state
until the scattering light
staggering stops and no matter
what the initial
state of the atom
bar where the dark state
is now 100% populated.
This is called coherent
population trapping.
Let me mention that
this coherent population
trapping can be some good
thing if you want to pump atoms
into a certain state and then
they stop scattering light.
They're not heated up anymore.
But sometimes you want the
atoms to scatter light.
For instance, in current
laser cooling experiments
with molecules,
there is a problem
that the multiplicity of the
angular momentum states, which
are suitable for laser
cooling in molecules
is such that you always
have a dark state.
So if you irradiate the
atoms with laser light,
they will not be on
a cycling transition.
The cycling
transition will stop.
So you have to play
additional tricks.
One is to apply a
transverse magnetic field
that the axis of the laser and
the quantization axis given
by the magnetic field are
in two different directions.
And then once the atom is
pumped into a dark state,
it will actually precess, Zeeman
precess out of the dark state.
Or magneto-optical
traps for molecules
use a magnetic field gradient,
which is rapidly switched,
because when you are
in a dark state for one
value of the magnetic field, you
just change the sign quickly.
And then the atoms are no
longer in the dark state
for the new situation
you've created.
So in other words, to have
these wonderful dark state,
which is a major
intellectual accomplishment
and eventually was exploited
in many experiments,
for a number of experiments
it's a real nuisance.
And you have to
find ways around it
to make sure that the atoms are
not stopping scattering light
and don't stop scattering light.
I gave you the simple
example that the dark state
exists for resonant excitation.
But as you can immediately
show, the dark state
also exists for
detuning of resonance.
The only thing which is
important as long as the two
lasers fulfill the two
photon resonance condition.
So you want the difference
between the two lasers
is the energy difference
between the two states.
Also remember if you
have two lasers which
are very different in power-- so
let's say one Rabi frequency is
much smaller than the other one.
So then the dark state,
the superposition
which is the dark
state, the dark state
is now predominantly which one?
The state with the
stronger coupling
or with the weaker coupling?
Well, it's the state
with the weaker coupling.
The dark state has
always a larger amplitude
in the state for which
the coupling is weaker.
And that of course
immediately makes a connection
to optical pumping.
For instance, if omega 1
the Rabi frequency is 0,
then the dark state
is what we started out
with a trivial
example, is a state g.
So you see that actually
what I taught you
about coherent
population trapping
is nothing else than
extension of the concept
of optical pumping.
OK, so we've talked
about the dark state
as a superposition
of state g and f.
But if you have a
two-dimensional Hilbert
space given by two
ground states g and f,
we can now find a new basis.
We have defined the dark state.
But now we can get
the orthogonal state,
which is the bright state.
It has a plus sign here and it
has the omega 1 and omega 2,
the Rabi frequencies reversed.
So this state is now orthogonal.
And you can now visualize the
preparation of the dark state
as follows.
We have the dark state.
We have the bright state.
The bright state, as you
can immediately verify,
is strongly coupled by the laser
field to the excited state.
So we have an excited state.
The laser fields-- well, its
two laser fields strongly
couple the bright state
to the excited state.
And then spontaneous emission--
two photon lights scattering--
can take you back to
either of the two states.
But now you see that the
concept of optical pumping,
which I started out
with a trivial example,
is now applying in the
new basis to the bright
and to the dark state.
And what happens is you
would, by optical pumping,
populate the dark state
and completely pump out
the bright state.
Just as a side remark, there
are lots of subtleties.
Most of them you will
probably see by yourself
by just inspecting the results.
But if you may
ask yourself, what
happens when the
Raman resonance is not
made, when the difference
between the two lasers
is not exactly the
difference between the two?
Well, then what you have
is you have a superposition
of ground and excited state.
So we have the two
ground states g and f.
But the two laser
fields have a phase
which evolves different from
the phase between g and f.
And suddenly, what you
have is relative-- I mean,
everything is relative to
the laser field, so to speak.
This plus sign turns
into a minus sign.
So therefore, if you have
pumped into the dark state,
but now the frequency
difference of the two lasers
is slightly different from the
frequency difference between g
and f, this mean in
essence that as time
goes by, with the frequency,
with the detuning away
from the two photon resonance,
the dark state will now
precess into the bright state.
And it is only for
the Raman resonance,
when it is exactly met, that you
have a long-lived dark state,
a dark state which is a 2
eigenstate of this Hamiltonian.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Would
the precession also
change omega 1 into omega 2?
PROFESSOR: No, we have
defined omega 1 and omega 2
as the Rabi frequencies
of the two lasers.
Omega 1 is a Rabi frequency
of the laser which
talks to, I think, the state g.
And omega two is
the Rabi frequency
of the laser which
talks to the state f.
So this doesn't change.
I'm just sort of telling you how
you may want to think about it,
that if you put in all of
the temporal phase factors,
on resonance, at least in
some dressed atom picture,
all the phase factors are 0.
Because the e to the i omega
t of the atomic wave function
is compensated by the
light atom coupling.
And therefore phase
factors just disappear,
and the state is stationary.
But if you write down what
happens as a function of time
to the state, and you couple
it as a function of time
to the laser field,
you will find out
that there is an
evolving relative phase
between the light field
and the atomic state.
And the essence of that
is that with these, there
will be a beat node at which
the dark state becomes bright
and the bright
state becomes dark.
OK.
One important application
of the dark state
is the STIRAP technique.
STIRAP is adiabetic
population transfer.
So STIRAP stands for
stimulated-- what is the r?
Stimulated Rapid
Adiabetic Passage?
AUDIENCE: I've seen
both rapid and Raman.
PROFESSOR: So we
have two choices.
It's both Raman and rapid.
A is adiabetic, p is passage.
And STI is stimulated,
because it's
a coherent stimulated process.
The idea is the following.
With this concept
of a dark state,
I can immediately
explain to you how,
by changing the intensities
of the laser beams,
you can make an adiabetic
transfer from one state
g to the other state f.
And this is important because
in many atomic physics
experiments, you
start with one state
and then you want to
prepare another state.
You always have the option of
having some suitable pi pulse
and going from one
state to the next.
But the pi pulse has
to be exactly pi.
You have to be careful
what the intensity
and duration of your pulse is.
But if you can adiabetically
go from one stage
to the other one,
this is terribly
robust against pretty
much everything.
And I want to now use the
concept of the dark state
to tell you how this
population transfer works.
But before I even get
into any explanation,
the picture is the following.
The dark state-- if you
change laser parameters,
you can change which
state is the dark state.
I gave you the simple example
if one laser beam is on,
the state g is the dark state.
If the other laser beam is on,
the state f is the dark state.
So if you switch one laser
beam off and the other one on,
you've changed the
definition of the dark state.
And as I want to show you is the
dark state, if we can set it up
in the situation that the dark
state is the absolute ground
state of the system, and you
know when you change parameters
of your Hamiltonian,
adiabeticity
tells you that you always
stay in the ground state.
See now, even
without any equations
you understand what adiabetic
population transfer is.
But let's work it out.
So we want to understand-- and
this is our adiabetic process--
what happens when the laser
parameters, omega 1 and omega
2, change slowly.
So for pedagogical
reasons, I will
drop all the assumptions
I'm making now,
but let me make them.
So let's discuss
degenerate states first.
So g and f are degenerate.
And let me also discuss
blue-detuned light.
And you will see
in a moment why.
So that would mean that-- and
let's set up the situation.
We have the state g, f, and e.
We have a green laser beam
and an orange laser beam.
And we know already, from
what we have just learned,
that this should be
transformed into--
and let me just be
more specific here.
I said I want to use
blue-detuned light.
So now we do what
we just learned.
We express things as the dark
state and the bright state.
And here we have
the excited state.
And the beauty of degeneracy
is that dark state
and bright state are
superposition states,
but since they're
superposition states
of two states with
the same energy,
I can draw them without
twisting my hand
or doing sort of a double line.
Anyway, but now what
happens is the following.
The bright state is
coupled to the excited
state by the two laser fields.
And the question is,
what is the energy
of the bright state
relative to the dark state?
Well, if I have a
blue-detuned laser beam,
I get an ac-Stark shift,
which increases the energy.
So therefore, the state
which sees the light, which
scatters photon--
scattering photon
means there is an
excited state admixture.
An excited state admixture means
there's an ac-Stark effect.
And the ac-Stark
effect is positive.
So therefore, the dark state
is-- the uncoupled state
is the lowest state in
the ground state manifold.
And even if you would
not generalize it
to multiple levels and all that,
if there is one dark state,
it's not upshifted by
the ac-Stark effect.
Whereas every state
which sees the light
is upshifted by
the ac-Stark effect
which provides a blue shift.
So the dark state is the
lowest quantum state.
So therefore, we can now
use the general concept
in quantum mechanics of
adiabetic state transfer
to achieve a perfect 100%
transfer from one ground
state to the other one by
tailoring as a function of time
our laser fields as follows.
We start out in a situation
where the only beam which is on
is-- I want to change that to
orange-- is the orange laser.
And when the orange laser is
on, then the dark state is g.
Then we ramp down
the orange laser.
But we ramp up the green laser.
And we have the situation
that initially g
and eventually f
is the dark state.
So this is a picture behind
the rapid adiabetic passage
from state g to f.
I want to point out that the
application of the two laser
pulse, first orange
and then green
is called the
counter-intuitive sequence.
Because if you ask
yourself the problem,
you're starting out
in state g and you
want to go over to
state f, which laser
would you first switch
on if you're in state g?
Well, if you want to
get out of state g,
you would say first
the green laser
to go up and then the
orange laser to go down.
So what I just said, first
the green and then the orange
is called the
intuitive sequence.
But STIRAP works with the
counter-intuitive sequence.
OK.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what's the
intuition we have with this?
PROFESSOR: Well, I
gave you the intuition.
I said, you want to
have a dark state.
The dark state is
the ground state,
the lowest state
of the manifold.
So you want to first make sure
that g is the ground state.
And then you turn
opposite your Hamiltonian,
and eventually f is
the ground state.
And this is exactly
the situation.
f is the ground state
with the green light on.
I've given you the
intuitive picture.
Now I will actually
come back to that.
There is the kind
of-- it's called
the magic of the
adiabetic state transfer
that if you always
stay in the dark state,
if you always stay
in the dark state,
you never populate
the excited state.
So it looks like
magic that you can
go from the ground
state to the final state
without having ever any
population in the excited
state.
And of course, can that be true?
No, because there is
no coupling direct.
So somehow in this picture
of adiabetic transfer always
staying in the dark and never
populating the excited state,
maybe we have
over-emphasized something.
We need a little bit
of excited state,
otherwise we cannot go there,
because our Hamiltonian does
not allow the direct
path from g to f.
So a lot of people
think that STIRAP
is a method where you
can go from g to f
without going through
the excited state.
I have many, many
people talking about it.
So I want to discuss it
in the next few minutes
and to some extent demystify it.
But since you're asking me-- now
in a black and white picture,
STIRAP is the way.
I'm correcting
myself in a moment,
but STIRAP is a way
where you can go directly
without going through
the excited state.
And this is done by the
counter-intuitive sequence
where you just want to keep
atoms in the dark state,
whereas the intuitive sequence
is really based on the fact you
want to take population here,
put population here and the
stimulate it down.
And this is not what
STIRAP is about.
Other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if there
is very strong coupling
to a fourth state from the
excited state, because you need
to-- the population needs to
travel through the excited
state in STIRAP, it's possible
to spoil the whole process.
PROFESSOR: We will
talk about it.
And actually in the next
minute, I want to sort of simply
calculate how many photons are
emitted during the passage.
And if you now say the photons
have a branching ratio,
this could be a branching
ratio to you fourth state.
But by just calculating what is
the time integrated population
in the excited state
multiplied with gamma,
this is the amount
of photons scattered.
And you can say if you try to
do a STIRAP with the bosons
then condensate, every time
you scatter, you heat up,
you reach momentum states
outside the condensate.
And those momentum states
are your fourth state.
So actually, by discussing how
much light scattering happens
in this transfer,
I will pretty much
talk indirectly about
how much population
is going into a fourth state.
So that's what you want
to understand now--
how true is the magic of the
dark state transfer where
we can go from one
state to the next
without ever going
through the excited state.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So are the two laser
frequencies the same for that?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I actually assumed that-- I
come to that in a second--
that the two states
are degenerate.
And for all this
dark state busyness,
we have to fulfill
the Raman resonance.
So if the two states
are degenerate,
then the two laser beams.
AUDIENCE: So then
what's the meaning
of increasing one of them?
We are satisfied--
PROFESSOR: OK.
One possibility is that
this is an m equals 0 state.
This is an m equals
minus 1 state.
This is m equals plus 1.
And this is sigma plus.
And this is sigma
minus radiation.
So yes, and this
was actually very
important for the whole
discussion of three level
coherence that this level can
only talk to the green laser,
this level can only talk
with the orange laser.
And we have two ways
to accomplish it.
One is by frequency difference.
But if you don't have
a frequency difference,
we need polarization
selection rules.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's sort
of a silly question.
In this particular case, if
I have all my atoms in g,
can I turn on the green laser?
Can I optically pump
everything to f?
Right?
And so in this
particular case, is there
an advantage of doing STIRAP
as opposed to optical pumping?
PROFESSOR: Yes there is,
and we'll talk about that.
There is a difference between
transferring population or only
transferring an amplitude.
And so it depends what you want.
If all you want is to
get the atoms from g
to f and you don't care how they
are heated up, so that's OK.
But the STIRAP process
is a stimulated process,
so you have momentum k and
here you have the momentum k2.
So you take the atoms
from an initial state
and put them in a very
well-defined momentum state.
So a PEC in one state
after STIRAP transfer
is in another
state, maybe if you
have the lasers in a
counter-propagating way
back to zero momentum.
Whereas if you do
optical pumping, which
involves spontaneous
emission, then you always
have dissipation.
You create entropy.
And because spontaneous
emission goes into many modes,
you have many different recoils,
and eventually your final state
is no longer a single state.
It has many different
momentum states involved.
So that's why we've been talking
here about a coherent transfer,
sort of assuming
that optical pumping
with spontaneous emission
and the many modes involved
is not what you want
because of heating.
OK, so lots of
interesting questions.
First, let's now drop all
the assumptions we've made.
So what happens when we
change from blue detuning
to red detuning?
Well, for blue detuning,
we use the argument
that adiabetically we
stay in the ground state,
but for red detuning
it's a higher state,
and we adiabetically
stay in the higher state.
Same thing.
What happens if f and
g are not degenerate?
Well, the argument
is the following.
It's the same result, and I
can quickly show that to you
by saying use the
dressed state basis.
You have the state g with Na
and Nb photons in laser beams.
Let me be consistent.
I call the operators
c and Na and Nc.
And if you now look
at the state f,
which has one photon less
here and one photon more here,
those two states are degenerate.
So I was just
showing the situation
if g and f are not
degenerate, here
we have a laser beam
with Na photons.
Here we have a laser
beam with Nc photons.
If we include the photons
in our description,
we have a degeneracy.
And that's what matters.
But what is relevant
of course is
you have this degeneracy
only when the energy
difference between g and
f is the energy frequency
difference between
the two laser beams.
So it is essential, and
you see that again here,
that the two photon
Raman resonance
condition has to be made.
So we've talked all the
assumptions so we know you can,
in a general system
you can transfer
between two hyperfine states.
You can use red or
blue detuned laser.
Everything is robust.
OK.
So STIRAP goes by the
name dark state transfer.
And what I want
to address now is,
what is the magic
which is going on?
How can we transfer
from state g to state f
without going to
the excited state?
And the answer is--
I gave it already
to you-- it's not possible,
because the only couplings we
have are the two couplings
which I've shown.
But-- and this is sort of the
gist you should carry away.
Since the whole transfer
is a coherent process--
and I will be more
exact in a moment--
we are not building
up population
in the excited state.
We're just building
up a small amplitude.
And the population is the
small amplitude squared.
It's, so to speak,
epsilon squared.
And so you win one
power of epsilon,
one power of the
small amplitude,
if you do a coherent
transfer, as compared
to incoherent
transfer, which relies
on shuffling over population.
And I want to show you
now how this pans out.
Jenny?
AUDIENCE: But in the limit
of infinitely adiabetic,
infinitely slow, you still
would have the transfer happen
without ever going into
the excited state, right?
PROFESSOR: Well, I will show you
that the integrated population
in the excited state goes as
one over the transfer time.
So if you allow an infinite
amount for the transfer,
you can make the population
[INAUDIBLE] slow.
But ultimately, what
I also want to show
you is that how much you
put into the excited state
depends-- and I think this
is a very satisfying result
for me-- depends
on your resources.
It depends on your laser power.
if you have infinite
laser power,
you can keep the population
infinitesimally small.
And if you have infinite time.
But if you go to the lab and
do an experiment and say,
I want to be done
in 24 hours, well
this defines your time budget.
And the strongest laser
you have in the laboratory
defines your laser power budget.
And given those two resources,
there is a small amount.
And I want to give you
an estimate for that.
And then we have to discuss,
is that small amount,
which we get in STIRAP,
does that really
stand out over other methods
to transfer population?
And the answer will
be interesting.
So let me just say, no.
Excited state is needed
as a stepping stone.
I want to give you
a quantitative touch
without doing too much math.
So let me just write down
Schrodinger's equation.
We have the three amplitudes,
the three states involved,
e, g, f.
Schrodinger's equation gives
us the time derivative.
c dot f.
Since we assumed in the
dressed state picture,
we can assume everything
is degenerate.
But now we have couplings.
And the only couplings
are-- and this
is what I was emphasizing--
between ground and excited
state with the Rabi frequency
omega 1 and between the state f
and the excited state with
Rabi frequency omega 2.
So the important part
is-- I can write it down,
but the third equation is
the one I want to focus,
that you can only build up
population in the final state
by transferring with
a Rabi frequency omega
two population from
the excited state.
So let me just assume
that Rabi frequency omega
1 equals omega 2
equals omega Rabi.
Let's have a symmetric situation
so I can now completely focus
how can you get from the excited
state to the final state,
but how you get from
the ground state,
from the state g to the excited
state is fairly symmetric here.
OK, so what we want is we want
that at the end of the transfer
time, t transfer,
the final state
amplitude is on the order of 1.
This would be 100%
percent transfer.
So therefore, just looking
at the differential equation
above, that means
that this here has
to be 1 divided by
the transfer time.
So therefore, we find that
for this adiabetic transfer,
the excited state
amplitude has to be--
and I neglect factors
on the order of 2
now-- has to be 1 over the Rabi
frequency times the transfer
time.
So the probability to
be in the excited state
is the amplitude squared.
And if you are asking, which I
think is a practical question
and I suggest to use this
as a figure of merit,
when we discuss how well, how
perfectly we have transferred
population, we can
now ask, what is
the probability of
spontaneous emission?
P spontaneous is the probability
to be in the excited state
times gamma
integrated over time.
So what we obtain
for that is yes,
it's proportionate to gamma.
But we have the excited
state amplitude squared.
We've multiplied with
the transfer time.
So therefore, what we
have in the denominator
is the laser power
or the Rabi frequency
squared times the transfer time.
So therefore, this
probability to go
to a spontaneous emission,
which is also the integrated
probability of having
populated the excited state,
it goes to 0 in the case that
you have infinite laser power
or that you're
infinitely patient.
So one question is, how long
can the transfer time be?
And this is actually
setting an limit to it.
We're talking about
a coherent transfer.
So the transfer time
has to be smaller
than the coherence
time of your system.
For instance, we do that
all the time in my lab.
If you go from on sublevel
to another sublevel,
and we have magnetic field
noise, if the magnetic field
noise is destroying the phase
relationship between the two
hyperfine states, then
the coherent transfer
gets interrupted, and
then eventually we
are no longer talking
about the amplitude.
We are talking about population
in the excited state.
OK, so we have this result,
which at least demystifies what
many people say--
actually I've heard
truly experienced researchers
in the field to say,
we can do the transfer
without ever populating
the excited state.
So the truth is what I
just derived for you.
But now we want to
compare it to what
would happen if you use
an incoherent picture.
If you use an
incoherent picture,
let's assume we
would use a pi pulse,
put all the population
in the excited state,
and then we would
stimulate it down.
So we have a pi pulse.
So we build our population.
And then we use a
second pi pulse.
Well, we would then have about
unity population in the excited
state.
It would emit light
at a rate gamma.
And it would take the time of
the inverse Rabi frequency,
the Rabi period, to
stimulate it down.
Now you can say, what
happens if-- maybe that's
dumb to have a pi pulse and
put all the population in, take
a pi over 20 pulse, put a little
bit population in, stimulate it
down.
The next batch, the next
batch, the next batch, but you
get exactly the same result,
because each population which
you've put into
the excited state
had to wait for a Rabi
period to be stimulated down.
So therefore in the
incoherent picture,
if you sort of transfer
batches of population,
you realize that the probability
for spontaneous emission
or for populating a four state
is independent of the transfer
time, because it cancels out.
If you do small
pieces of population,
you have a smaller
rate of emission,
but you integrate for longer
and the two temporal factors
cancel out.
And now you realize that
the coherent transfer
is more favorable by another
power of omega Rabi times t
transfer in the denominator.
So that's why people
prefer STIRAP.
Questions about that?
Can you suggest
another method how
we could transfer population
from one state to the next?
I gave you two examples.
One was this magic, or not so
magic, dark state transfer.
The other one is
a method where we
put population, stimulated it
down, next batch of population,
stimulate it down.
What is another process which we
can do to transfer population?
AUDIENCE: Landau-Zener?
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
PROFESSOR: Landau-Zener?
Actually, the STIRAP
is a Landau-Zener.
The dark state is
always the lowest state.
There is a crossing
sort of in between,
but it's an avoided crossing.
Actually, in a way, you
may want to think about it.
The STIRAP is actually
a Landau-Zener transfer
between where the lower
state is a dark state,
the upper state
is a bright state.
Will?
AUDIENCE: I still
have a question.
So Landau-Zener [INAUDIBLE]
But the STIRAP scheme
is sensitive to the
run-on resonance.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely it is.
AUDIENCE: So how robust is
it against small violations
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, I gave
you already the hint
when I discussed that if you
are detuned from the Raman
resonance, this detuning,
at the detuning frequency
would be between dark
and bright state.
So this picture what is
dark and what is bright
is scrambled up by that.
So in other words,
as long as you're
inverse detuning is smaller than
the transfer time, you're OK.
Because the dark state
is the dark state.
But if during the transfer
time you turn the dark state
into a bright state,
you've completely
messed up the scheme.
So in other words, I know people
in this hallway, in my group
want to STIRAP transfer
between molecules.
And we have to
stabilize our lasers.
So we have automatically
little bit laser fluctuations.
But if you do the
transfer in a millisecond,
it is sufficient to have the
laser frequency under control
at the kilohertz level.
So that's a requirement.
But back to my question.
We have discussed sort
of an incoherent transfer
and we've discussed STIRAP.
Can you suggest
another method how
you can go from one
count state to the next?
AUDIENCE: We talked
about optical pumping.
PROFESSOR: Optical pumping?
Yes, but optical
pumping means we
really go with
spontaneous emission.
And then we have 100%
So we want a process where
we go from one momentum state
to another momentum state.
Well--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Optical pumping is a
two-photon process.
Actually, everything's a
two-photon process here.
But optical pumping
is actually a process
where we have a Raman
to photon transition.
The first leg is stimulated.
The second one is spontaneous.
But I would suggest now
what [INAUDIBLE] said,
let's have a two photon
Raman transition.
So we want to go from state g
to state f with two photon Raman
transition.
Let's assume we have
a detuning delta.
So now, do you have
any expectations
whether these-- we
can do a pi pulse.
Two photon Raman transition is
a two photon Rabi frequency.
I'll remind you
in a second of it.
And if you do a
pi pulse in that,
we have half a Rabi
oscillation, which
takes us from cg to f and
we have 100% transfer.
So do you have an
expectation if this Raman
process how will it turn out
to be in our figure of merit,
how many photons are
emitted from the excited
state during the transfer?
Will it be the same as STIRAP?
Will it be the same as
in population transfer?
Will it be something else?
AUDIENCE: You have to scale.
PROFESSOR: It will
scale with the detuning,
but-- OK, what I will do is
actually-- I will in a moment
say, OK.
We have a certain laser.
What I'm going to say?
We have to compare
apples with apples.
And here we have the
detuning as a parameter.
And what I want to
replace is I will--
what will replace the
detuning by the time it
takes to do the pi pulse.
So the detuning is
determined by the condition
that we want to do the transfer
in the same time as the STIRAP.
So this will eliminate
the detuning.
So we want to use
the same resources.
Our resources are
time and laser power.
And we want to use our resources
of time and laser power
in the same way for the
two photon transition.
So the question is
what happens to-- what
is the answer to the question,
how much excited state is
involved in the two photon Raman
process as compared to STIRAP?
Do you have an expectation?
Who of you is doing
STIRAP in the laboratory?
A few people, yeah.
Actually, I know that
99-- my observation
is that 99% of the people
say STIRAP is special
because it's a dark
state transfer.
And when I started to confront
famous people in the field
and say the two photon Raman
process does exactly the same,
they were completely surprised.
Anyway I want to show
you in one equation
that the two photon
Raman process has
exactly the same integrated
population in the excited
state, and therefore it is as
good-- the two photon Raman
process performs exactly as
well as the so-called dark state
transfer, where you never go
through the excited state.
And this for me
completely demystifies it,
because the two
photon Raman process
has in common with the STIRAP
that everything is coherent.
And if everything
is coherent, it
means we are not
building a population.
We are only building up
amplitude in the excited state.
So let me just show
you in one equation
that indeed it works
out in that way.
It's also a nice way
to quickly recapitulate
what we learned in
the previous chapter
about two photon transitions.
So the two photon Rabi
frequency is nothing else
than the product of the two
Rabi frequencies divided
by the detuning.
And of course as-- if you
use studied larger and larger
detuning as you said,
everything will slow down.
But we know that
the transfer time
will be the inverse of the
two photon Rabi frequency.
And this is delta
over omega square.
So therefore, we will eliminate
delta from our equations
by replacing it by
the time it will
take to perform a pi pulse
between the two ground states.
OK, so what is the probability
to be in the excited state?
Well, we've done the theory
of the ac-Stark effect.
We have beaten perturbation
theory to death.
You know the first
order admixture
is omega Rabi over delta
and the probability
is omega Rabi squared
over delta squared.
So therefore, the probability
to spontaneously emit a photon
is omega Rabi squared over delta
squared times gamma times t
transfer.
And this is nothing else than
gamma divided by omega Rabi
squared times t transfer.
So if you use a Raman pulse
to transfer the population
coherently, the
integrated population
of the excited state, which is a
measure for heating and measure
for winding up in the
wrong state, emission
to a false state is inversely
proportional to your laser
power and inversely
proportional to the time
you can afford to
do the transfer.
Exactly the same as for STIRAP.
And the limit to the
transfer time in both cases
is set by the coherence time.
Try to tell people who do
STIRAP that a two photon Raman
pulse would do exactly
the same as STIRAP,
at least in populating
the excited state.
They will be surprised.
Because here, you explicitly
go through the excited state.
We don't have a
counter-intuitive sequence.
We switch on both
lasers simultaneously.
But I think this for me
illustrates or completely
demystifies what people have
said about the dark state
transfer and the STIRAP process.
Any question?
Cody?
AUDIENCE: Why do
people use STIRAP?
What's the advantage?
PROFESSOR: Well, why are you
using Landau-Zener sweeps when
you go from one hyperfine
state to the next,
and why don't you use a pi
pulse with your f generator,
because it's more robust.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
As you said [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But similar,
if you detune--
if you detune your-- the
condition is the same.
If you have your two Raman
laser and you detune them,
you no longer have
resonant Rabi oscillations.
You have off-resonant
Rabi oscillations.
And you will find if you want
to do the transfer in half
a period, you have to
make sure that you don't
get one cycle of
the beat node or one
cycle of the detuning
in your transfer time.
So the condition for the
frequency stability for the two
photon Raman and
the STIRAP I think
are pretty exactly identical.
So I think it's pretty
much the robustness.
And you have to decide what
you need and what you want.
For instance, if you have laser
beam and the laser beam has
an inhomogeneous profile,
you cannot meet the pi pulse
condition for the atoms in
the middle and at the edge
of your laser beam.
But in STIRAP you just
provide plenty of extra power
and then everything is robust
against the laser beam profile.
So there are clearly
advantages like that.
But all what I point
out is the advantage
is not the population
of the excited state.
It's the same.
Questions?
OK.
So this is dark
state and STIRAP.
Our next topic is lasing
or gain without inversion.
So in other words,
I want to show you
what was actually rather
recent accomplishment
that this common belief that you
need population in the excited
state, which is larger
in the ground state,
for optical gain and
lasing is not true.
Well, it's true for
two level system,
but it's not true when you
have more than two levels.
And I discuss it here for the
case of a three-level system.
And this is really insight which
came as recent as in the '80s.
One reference is the person
who pioneered a lot of work
on three-level systems and
provided a lot of insight
was Steve Harris at Stanford.
And this was a paper
in the late '80s which
enunciated the
possibility of having
lasing without inversion.
And when you are a
graduate student like me,
who was educated earlier,
you say, gee whiz.
That's not what I
learned in class.
But of course it's
often the small sprint.
It's the assumption
for two-level system.
So the secret behind
lasing without inversion
is that you can have
cancellation of absorption
by interference.
In other words, this belief
that you need inversion
comes that you want that
the stimulated emission is
stronger than the absorption.
But if you have a three-level
system, you have to be careful.
We have interference effect.
And what I want to show you is
that we can create a situation
where we have destructive
interference for absorption,
but we don't have
destructive interference
for stimulated emission.
So therefore, we can now
afford to have more population
in the ground state, because
the absorption out of the ground
state does not have to be
suppressed by minimizing
the population in
the ground state.
We have an interference effect,
which suppresses absorption
from the ground
state population.
And therefore, the
ground state population
can be larger than in
a two-level system.
I could simply tell you
you can hide population
in the dark state,
end of discussion,
and you get the basic idea.
But the concept of
lasing without inversion
is richer than that.
It's connected to the dark
state, but there is more to it.
So that's why I want to spend
the rest of today's class
in discussing this concept.
So I want to discuss it in
the simplest possible scheme.
So I want to discuss
first the simple system.
In the end, this
is not the system
in which it has
been accomplished.
But I think what you
realize is I draw you
up a very simple scheme.
I make all assumptions,
and there is maybe
no atomic, no suitable atom
where you can realize it.
But then I will do what I've
done so often in this class.
I turn around and say, but if
you go to a tri-state basis,
we can exactly engineer that.
So in other words, if you
need a certain level scheme
and you don't get it, you
can just take another level,
put it there with a strong
laser as a virtual level,
and you get the level
scheme you want.
And in a dress
state description,
you have exactly
the idealized level
scheme I'm presenting to you.
So therefore with
that justification,
let me just try to give
you the simple scheme where
you can understand
this absorption
cancellation by interference.
I mean, later in
the end, we want
to use lambda systems
with two stable ground
state, two hyperfine states.
That's how all the
research is done.
But now I assume
we have a V system.
So we have two excited states
and we have one ground state.
And I want to assume that by
coupling through radiation,
spontaneous emission,
those excited states
couple to the same continuum.
I want to say that this is
an important assumption.
If you have two states,
hyperfine states,
n equals plus 1,
n equals minus 1,
which would emit photons
of different circular
polarization, no.
They are not coupling
to the same continuum.
They would be distinguishable,
and then certain interference
effects will not happen.
So eventually, the magic
of quantum interference
comes if it is absolutely
indistinguishable
which excited state
has emitted the photon.
So we have to really be--
set up something like this.
So it must be fundamentally
impossible to distinguish
photons emitted through
one state or the other.
So we know already if
we treat the system,
we couple the atoms
to the continuum.
That means in the
end, that those states
acquire a certain width.
And yes, this is a situation
we want to discuss.
So what we have set
up now is a situation
where we have, with
these two states, two
indistinguishable paths
to scatter photons.
So let's say we take
the ground state
and we shine laser light on it.
It's a two photon process.
A photon goes in,
a photon comes out.
And we can now go
through excited state 1,
through excited state out
then a photon comes out
and eventually we have now the
coupled through this two photon
process the ground state
to continuum of modes.
But those two processes
to go through e1 and e2
are indistinguishable.
So I will give you
immediately an expression
where in perturbation theory,
we are not adding intensities.
We are adding the
two amplitudes.
It's like a
double-slit experiment.
Or in other words, the
situation I want to discuss now
is the following.
We have all of the population
in the ground state.
We have the two excited states.
And our laser is
tuned in between.
And now we can scatter light.
We've talked about really
scattering and such.
And you know that for an
infinitely heavy atom,
the emitted radiation is a delta
function at the incident light.
And you will not
know, you can never
know which excited state was
involved in the scattering.
So we assume that
we have excited
state-- which one
is the lower one?
I think e1.
This is e2.
And our laser beam is detuned.
We have a detuning of delta
1 and delta 2 respectively.
So now we have to add amplitudes
when we do perturbation theory.
So in second order
perturbation theory,
for the light
scattering, if you want
to derive Fermi's golden rule as
we have done a number of times
here, you remember,
the critical part--
I'm not writing down the whole
expression-- the critical part
is sort of a product of two
matrix element or two photon
matrix element which takes
us from the ground state
through the light atom
coupling to the excited state.
And then from the excited state
why are the coupling eventually
back to the ground state, which
is now a continuum of modes.
And we sum over
all possible modes.
And what we have here is
the detuning denominator.
Well, if you want to
do a little bit better,
I'm just mentioning
here for completeness,
we want to add the
imaginary part.
That's more placeholder for a
command I want to make later.
It's not really essential.
But the new thing I
want to discuss now
is that since we have two
excited states and not one,
we have to sum over
the two excited states,
and it's a coherent sum.
So if I detune between-- if
my laser detuning is tuned
in between, then
delta 1 is positive
and delta 2 is negative.
So therefore, we do a sum
here with opposite signs.
And if I can neglect the
gamma, assuming the gamma
is small or much smaller
than the detuning,
then I'm just adding up two
numbers with opposite sign.
And depending now on the matrix
element, if they're identical
I get a cancellation if
I'm detuning half between.
But even if the matrix
element are different,
I will always find a
detuning where the sum is 0.
So to the extent that I can
neglect the imaginary part,
the gamma in the denominator,
I have now this situation
that this is 0.
It vanishes for a certain
laser frequency, omega 0,
tuned between the
levels e1 and e2.
And what I've assumed here is
that the detunings are larger
than the decay widths, and
therefore I can neglect that.
Any questions about that?
So OK.
Very trivially,
two excited states
which are indistinguishable.
It's the modern
version of Feynman's
double-slit experiment.
We add up the amplitudes
and by necessity, we get 0.
But that sounds so trivial,
but it took a Steve Harris,
some genius person to
invent it, to realize
that when we have light at omega
0, it would be absorbed by e1.
It would be absorbed by e2.
But it is not absorbed
in the situation
we have with e1 and e2.
But now we have to make the
connection that the statement
that we need inversion
for lasing was related
to absorption, but now we
have cancelled absorption.
So now what we want
to do is we want
to create a situation
where we have lasing.
We want to put population
into the excited state.
But the population
in this excited state
will be much, much smaller than
the population in the ground
state.
So you're not even
close to inversion.
So let me draw the diagram.
We have lots and lots
and lots and lots
of population in
the ground state.
We have 0 population in e1.
And in e2, we just
have a little bit.
And now you would say, well,
you don't have inversion.
How can you get lasing?
But if we have now a cavity
at frequency omega 0,
then you can say the Lorentzian
profile of the excited state e2
overlaps with omega 0.
So at least you have some
possibility for the excited
state e2 to decay
into the cavity mode.
And therefore, a very weak
field in the cavity mode
will be amplified by
stimulated emission
without suffering
any absorption.
So therefore it will be
amplified and we have gain.
So if you have a
cavity at omega 0,
we have gain because we have
some stimulated emission
at omega 0 but no absorption.
Of course, if you
would tune your cavity
to be in a resonance
with e2, you
would have more
stimulated emission,
but you would have
much more absorption
and you would not be able to
get a net gain for a small probe
field.
So you would not have lasing.
So you can say that what
we have achieved here
in a three-level system,
we have accomplished
destructive interference
for absorption.
But the way how we've put
population just in e2,
we have not any
destructive interference
for the stimulated gain.
So we have tweaked on
the lasing equation,
on the laser equation
the absorption part,
but not the stimulated
emission part by interference
in a three-level system.
So how can this be realized?
Let me just give you the
first possible realization
and then I think we should stop.
We could, in
principle, realize it
with hydrogen and a
DC electric field.
Remember, hydrogen has the
1s level, has the 2s level,
and the 2p state.
And you all had a nice, little
nice homework assignment
that when you have a DC field,
you actually couple 2s and 2p.
And if your DC field is
stronger than the Lamb shift,
you actually create
a superposition
of 2s and 2p states.
And now, if you tune your
laser right in between,
you have a dark resonance.
So the situation
is if I would now
plot the absorption
versus frequency,
you would find that if you're in
resonance with the upper state
you absorb, but then
even in between,
there is this notch where
you have zero absorption.
So for this simple
case with hydrogen
in a DC electric field,
the dark resonance
occurs when you
have equal detuning.
You have an equal detuning
for the atom with respect
to the two states.
And I like to sort of connect
it to classical physics.
You know that
absorption is related.
When you absorb, you
have light scattering.
The photons are
not disappearing.
They're just scattered
into other modes.
That's what absorption is about.
And classically,
light scattering
comes because you have an
oscillating dipole moment.
But what happens is if you have
this coherent superposition
and you're right in between,
you have a positive detuning
with one harmonic oscillator
and a negative detuning
with the other
harmonic oscillator.
So if you drive an harmonic
oscillator-- and this is one
and this is the other--
with positive detuning,
with red detuning,
the dipole moment
is in phase with
the electric field.
In the other case,
it's out of phase.
So now you have the
two excited states
and you're driving two equal
but opposite dipole moments
in those two states.
And therefore, the two
dipole moments add up to 0.
Therefore the laser, just
using our understanding
of a simple harmonic
oscillator, is not
creating any dipole moment.
Therefore, we're not
scattering any light
and therefore we're not
absorbing any light.
So this is how you can now
realize in the hydrogen atom
using DC magnetic field and
creating this level structure,
you can create lasing
without inversion.
But I will tell you
on Wednesday-- no,
today is Wednesday--
next Monday,
next week that we
don't have to deal
with the difficulties
of hydrogen atoms
in the laboratory.
We can just use our
favorite alkalize
and dress the alkalize
up with laser beams
and eventually create
the same situation
with an atom which
is experimentally
much simpler to address.
Any questions?
OK, one more week to go.
See you on Monday.